the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it but with the
adana you can use it in perfect
alignment with your life the adan app is
already used by 40 million believers
around the world why because it caters
to your islamic lifestyle on top of this
a lot of times you get the
dear brothers and sisters welcome back
to this podcast in the dunya
there we go
okay one of the biggest things that i
feel like people don't talk about a lot
is the physical fitness
why
you tell me no why do why does no one
talk about it i don't know man
i feel like it's one of those things
where
we're just kind of
being
uh motivate not motivate we're being um
encouraged to focus more on the akira
which is important 100
but there's so much focus on that that
you forget the dunya like we were
talking about in the
it was either in the last episode or
just in another episode in general
and it's like
if you forget this
and your body starts going
like what's going to happen when you're
married
response
whole bunch of nothing yeah she's right
bro like her attraction to you is just
gonna steadily decline and then on top
of that she's probably gonna let herself
go even more so then your attraction to
her is gonna steadily decline
so like what does this do
what does this actually do
for the relationship it does nothing
it does nothing so
that's the question that i want to bring
up to y'all
you know like why why has it gotten to
this point and what can we do about it
what can what can a brother today
do about this situation well let's say
we can give different examples we can
give one example of a brother who
is about to get married inshallah
and we can give another example of a
brother who's already married but he's
just having an issue maybe just not
taking care of himself right
and we can give
a example of a brother who is
taking care of themselves and he is in a
marriage so that way they make clear
distinctions right
before we jump into this i do want to
pre-face before rami takes over
that everything we do say is
just from our experience you know we're
not here giving
islamically you know
quran and sunnah advice all those a lot
of the stuff is inspired
but this is more so just generally
our experience of learning the ropes of
fitness
health
wellness
working out resistance training
testosterone and all that type of stuff
and the importance of this in an islamic
paradigm because we understand as an
ummah we must grow we must be strong we
must unite and to have more kids and to
have our kids be strong and resist the
fitnah of today's world
health and fitness is a huge part of it
bro
not submitting to big pharma and
prescription medications and being weak
and
all of this stuff
brother you should only pray five times
a day you don't need to do anything else
listen alhamdulillah to everyone praying
five times a day to barack
that's that's literally the goal you
know that's that's the bare minimum
though like i think you know praying
fathoms it is muslims that's that's what
we're supposed to be doing anyway that's
obligatory right what we're not focusing
on is the health and fitness aspect of
it right so inshallah that's what we're
gonna be talking about today one reason
to kind of answer another's question on
why
this is not something that we're talking
about i believe is because
it's not something that's that's thought
of to be important in islam right it's
something that's not thought of to be
rewarding in islam it's not thought of
to be something as
as you know
worthy that allah would love from us you
know
if you you know raise your kids not
talking about the importance of
sadhakajarya giving charity you know for
the sake of allah to those in need
giving zakat they might think bro we
don't need to you know
give any money to the
poor people to the needy they see their
parents you know counting their dollars
and not really giving money back and
being a little stingy they might think
it's not really that important
right so what i'm trying to say is
if we have a perceived importance of
something in islam right
whether or not it's from the religion
we'll devote ourselves to it
fitness believe it or not is something
from the dean of islam contrary to what
a lot of people think super important
that we talk about this and yeah rami
why don't you take over
uh well i mean to talk about it from an
aesthetic perspective you know it's
important that we have the right knee
according to it you know you know
actually i would say working out could
be something that is a fitness for
someone if they're too focused on you
know how they look and that's something
i know you can go into a lot of that i'm
sure you've seen a lot of it as well
um but yeah i mean if you have the knee
of getting bigger can look at you let go
you know he's the man who's looking at
him
yeah ego
you know feeling their ego that you know
why would you be worried about lost my
dad or something like that but if you
look at it like i want to look big so
people don't mess with me my brothers my
sisters and muslims and so on and so
forth you know maybe that's maybe that's
something that was with that would be
more or
like i want to physically get stronger
so i can literally lift more so i'm more
capable so i'm stronger so i can lift
the car if i need to i can throw a car
if i need to i can beat up a couple
people if i need to which you can talk
about that as well because it doesn't
always have to do with muscle actually
doesn't have to do much with muscle and
more the actual fighting the skill all
right i want to make that clear well
some people have that knee or that
intention of i want to get stronger so
i'm more capable when i'm fighting and
that's something that is beautiful um
or looking you know better for uh your
wife you know some sisters might come
but no i like the dad bother whatever
cup
how dare you um
but uh i don't know i've never
known a sister who would actually
talk about it
that would actually say something like
that you know what it is
they're lying they are
but what if they they're trying to say
that they're not lying and they say that
they like that kind of body
they only like it because it's
non-threatening and they they don't feel
like they have to compete and they don't
feel like they really have to do much
for themselves
you know what i'm saying they don't have
to take care of themselves as much
because it's like they see their man and
it's like their man's like uh so they
can be
but if they got a oh mashallah man they
also gotta like step up to the plate
you know
that might sound a little egotistical
but it's just the fact that this
yeah yeah
so how do we start brothers and sisters
with that all being said insha'allah we
know through islam that a strong
believer is better than the weak
believer although there is both as
brother romney always mentions so what
can we do to start i think understanding
that you know today we want to talk
about two main things and the brothers
can jump in if there's anything else you
guys have in mind but to start all this
off to jump start this
i think there should be a good amount of
being lean
and resistance training all right so
these are the two main things we're
gonna be talking about today um i do
think however
resistance training is extremely
underrated meaning lifting weights
working out you know hitting the gym
getting those you know machines free
weights compound lifts
those gains all of that i think all of
this stuff
is going to make you extremely
intimidating bro
and make you extremely powerful and no
i'm just playing that's not the goal you
know well why are you finished yeah
the goal is to yeah the goal is to get
your physique right and why resistance
training is extremely
perceived as unimportant today is
because people just think you know you
gotta go on the treadmill you gotta lose
some weight okay i understand you can
lose some weight but resistance training
and science has proven this lately and
i'll put some studies in the description
insha allah resistance training is the
most effective mode of fat loss compared
to anything else
because resistance training boosts your
testosterone increases your muscle mass
meaning most of the food you eat is
going to repair your muscles if you're
working out a lot instead of being
stored as fat um it's going to increase
your muscle distribution and fat
distribution is going to decrease it um
it's going to increase your human growth
hormone it's going to make you look more
aesthetic bro it's going to push out
more muscle so even if you have fat it's
going to you're gonna look more
aesthetic
and it decreases this thing called your
body fat percentage
it's not gonna decrease your body fat
per se but it's gonna increase your lean
body mass which mathematically will
decrease your total body fat percentage
and your body thought percentage is the
only thing that decides how lean you
look not your body fat i guarantee you
most of the brothers and sisters that
are watching this thinking they're
overweight
dwayne johnson probably has more body
fat in pounds than them however he has
more muscle than y'all too so his body
fat percentage which is just your pounds
of body fat over your total pounds of
your weight is much lower and that's why
he looks much leaner so anyway this is
resistance training we can go into that
and then lastly we have fat loss which
is just losing fat i think
science has proven this any woman that
says otherwise is capping but having a
lean physique bro really is everything
when it comes down to it and before we
even get into that i think is it's very
important to address
uh the times that we live in
and just like
how being fat is like being normalized
let's talk about this bro you know it's
it's being normalized this is normal now
like how can that be normal look i get
it your body puts on fat that's normal
because that's a survival thing that's
what allah made our bodies to do
which is beautiful but
to be so fat they're like you're obese
or you just body positivity
you're so overweight that like you can't
even get up a few flights of stairs
without being completely dead
or you look at yourself in the mirror
and you can't even look at yourself
because you're just ashamed with what
you're seeing like how can
no how can you lie to yourself and be
like oh you know what this is actually
good i should be happy i should be proud
of this when it's like in reality you
you look in the mirror and you don't
even like what you're seeing and i think
this is a
big thing right because
we live in this society we are affected
by society so
if this is a way that society is moving
if people are not taking active measures
to
guard themselves
and to like focus on themselves and be
the best version of themselves
i mean like it would make
it would make sense that they would be
bahumsa bahamsa what if they what if
they have a metabolic condition what if
they have what if they have thyroid
conditions what if they they're like
obesity because of their genetics what
if she's pregnant and she just
what do you say to that bro hums is not
here bro i know i know that but it's
it's the reference
what about his umbrella
there's gonna be people in the comments
saying hey my uncle's brother's son was
born with this you know immunological
condition and autoimmune disorder he
just stacks on fat bro we're not talking
about these honor are you talking about
these people nah and even then like
no disease has been made that allah
hasn't made a cure for
and like when there's something wrong
with you like you're supposed to seek
how to like heal this or cure it you
know like you wouldn't just be all right
with having a tumor in your body would
you
not at all right so
if you can see okay a little bit of fat
on your body not a big issue but if you
got a ton of fat on your body and you're
looking at yourself in the mirror and
like you clearly like something's just
like you even repulsed by yourself that
should let you know something's off
right and you should you should seek to
fix this
i have i'm not going to say i don't have
much respect for people that are out of
weight
i'll say i don't have
much respect for people that are
extremely out of weight and they're not
doing anything about it if you're doing
anything about it cool let's start today
today can be day one right
i know you're not talking about the
people that are you know
you're not trying to normalize being
four percent body fat either i just want
to make this right clear from the jump
that we're not seeing the six-pack abs
the abercrombie and fitch models that
you guys see this is like the the normal
physique that we should be not but what
angel's saying is when you go on shows
like tlc and you see my 300 pound fiance
the fact that they're having new people
every episode just that's a problem bro
right we can't be having this many 300
pound fiances whatsoever so what do we
do about this bro
all right so
we can put this very simple
okay
first you got to know
what your goal is are you trying to put
on muscle
are you trying to put on or remove fat i
was gonna say put on fat
are you trying to put on muscle are you
trying to get rid of fat which one are
you trying to do figure that out and
then from there now you have an
understanding in which direction you're
gonna be heading in if your goal is to
put on muscle
you're going to be eating
a calorie surplus
now
a lot of times you see in the fitness
field like the calorie surplus like
people just like force feeding
themselves yeah like a dirty ball yeah
you don't need to do this a little
surplus is enough yeah 200 300 calories
that's it you don't even need that much
mm-hmm that you that's fine that's one
or three three you could even do like a
hundred calories yeah what like
one tablespoon of peanut butter that's
it
and so i told romney like and this is i
got it from hamza as well you know so
shout out to you my guy if you are some
reason watching this but um you eat til
you're full
and i just eat one little bite a little
bit more that's
[Laughter]
if your goal is to put on muscle as a
man
you're going to eat until you're good
and then just eat a little bit more
maybe one two
three or let's say one or three you want
to keep it sooner right but one
two or three
just little bites extra
and you will see over time your body
will begin to put on muscle now this is
not talking about like what you have to
do in the gym
and in terms of um
time of time
time no
um
what's that thing
the overloading
progressive overload progressive
overload we'll talk about that as well
this is just talking about eating okay
eating we're trying to keep it very
simple in steps so you can understand
um gold to put on muscle you're just
going to eat to your food and then you
one to three little bites more now if
you're trying to lose weight
you're gonna be wanting to do the
opposite yeah this one
you um
you can't
you can't eat to your food or you can't
eat to your good because then you're
obviously eating too much maintenance or
bulk yeah yeah you got to be in a
deficit the easiest way that i found to
do this without having to count too much
is you break your
your um meal frequency so maybe
maybe you're someone who does like three
meals a day
right maybe with some snacks as well
so what you would do in the beginning is
maybe like cut out one of your snacks
but then start going to the gym right
we'll talk about the gym part in a
second here but you just cut out one of
your snacks and you see how your body is
reacting right are you losing weight on
the scale is it is slightly going down
and um don't
get too focused on the skill number
because that's just
it's an indicator kind of letting you
know okay am i making progress am i not
making progress
but you have to look in the mirror like
are there changes occurring and if if
there isn't if you plateaued if you kind
of stop what you do now is you remove
another one of your snacks so if you
want to get real intense with it
you just remove a meal
and then now you have two meals a day
and then if you really want to like make
it a lot easier on yourself or semi-easy
depending on how well you can fast cut
it down to one meal a day
with one meal a day like there's so many
people that do this where they don't
even count the calories
they just fast they drink water
and then when it's time to eat they'll
let themselves eat and usually
they'll get full before they even reach
maintenance calories and and what this
means is they're getting food before
they get to the point where
their body has enough
all right now what do i mean by enough
here actually do you guys want me to
continue or do you want to by all means
bro you're on the road yeah romney bro
like you're the expert here yeah
bachelor of science in nutrition and
health and wellness
okay
so
um
what's the thing
how dare you tldr bro i just kind of
want to before you you know think about
what you were going to say i want to
just give a quick succinct summary of
what we talked about so far for anyone
that's here trying to take notes or
anything like that yeah uh you know yes
there's ways to count calories and all
that we're going to be talking about
that maybe later or i talk about that on
my own channel right well uh editor you
can pop it up right here shameless plug
but what we are talking about for our
purposes here for the average person
that just wants to get healthy you know
into a healthy weight range is if you
want to gain weight you should be eating
just a few more bites every single meal
or every time you eat just a little bit
more and you will notice your weight
goes up because calories what are
calories right we should talk about this
too because we don't want to like
overload them with information
calories are just a unit of energy just
like mass is a unit of weight
what am i saying bro kilograms is a unit
of mass uh kilometers is a unit of
distance
um
let's say
you get me so similarly
calories are just a unit of energy
kilojoules is another unit of energy
yeah and we track these calories as
energy that we must consume every day to
maintain our body weight for our organs
to function um everything right
we need a certain amount of energy or
calories every day just to basically
live just to maintain our weight just to
just to have energy for our organs to
function for our brain for everything
but the thing is when you eat more than
this number than your caloric
maintenance number you gain weight and
you're in a caloric surplus
that's basically what i was saying
to get into the zone of gaining weight
it doesn't matter if you want to gain
muscle or fat if you just want to gain
weight metabolically speaking you must
be in a caloric surplus and if you want
to lose weight you must be in a caloric
deficit so when anejo said you just want
to eat a little bit more bites that's
initially going to help you but what
happens is your initial surplus of 100
or 200 or 300 or however much more
you're eating calorie wise
eventually it becomes your maintenance
and then you just got to eat more and
that's the simple answer and you do the
opposite when you want to lose weight
so to keep it even more simple
and everything that you eat and drink
usually has the nutrition facts on the
back it'll tell you numbers
don't take these numbers too seriously
they're just like estimates you know
because sometimes you have ones that'll
say like 100 calories but then when you
look into it it's actually like 300 or
400 calories
so dumb you got to get the serving size
right too yeah yeah yeah but
uh again to simplify everything
if you were trying to put on muscle
eat a few more bites if you're trying to
lose
just limit the meal frequency
right and eat more
foods with like fiber so like vegetables
whole grains fruits and then actual
meats
you know because if you eat the sweet
stuffs
listen i'm not gonna say anything i'm
not gonna say like oh no you shouldn't
be doing that you know
we all know damn well we should and
shouldn't be doing
but
when we eat sweets
it's not safe [ __ ]
like
actually i'm not even gonna say but
yeah
you know what i was gonna say i was
gonna i was gonna say this reminds me of
something i was talking to one of my
boys with um about like your nufs or
like just sugar or anything in general
it's kind of like a wild animal you know
sugar or whatever
the more you get or the more you feed
this wild animal the hungrier it's going
to get yeah whereas if you can control
these cravings and these urges right
it's kind of like taming that wild
animal which is a much more sustainable
way to live and it's so weird man like
if i give you guys a box of dates
but how many of those dates will you be
able to get down before you're like hey
i'm good i don't really want any more
dates i'll be a handful bro a handful a
month ago yeah same thing like a handful
is probably maybe like
five three or four or five servers but
if you gave me a box of oreos bro i
could get through five boxes of oreos
done five boxes you got the milk dip
done game over it's like every bite you
take from sugar you want another bite
yeah the more sugar you have the more
you want but it's weird with fruit
you take that bite and like maybe you
might want more but like
you just progressively get to the point
you're like i don't really want anymore
that's the satiating effect of fiber you
know why it is also
in oreos and twinkies and pop-tarts and
all this garbage they add these
chemicals that are literally addicting
bro but not just that they're calorie
dense so i do want to talk about this a
little bit i don't want to go on a
tangent though because you had a
wonderful point you were going to bring
up something new on your face mashallah
but there's a thing about calorie
density what is calorie density if you
guys are struggling to lose fat if you
guys are struggling to lose weight if
you want to get into a caloric deficit
and not feel starving all the time right
because we all heard of these extreme
diets thousand calories and all this
we're not doing that right
calorie density is the key that you need
to survive and to end to succeed that's
what i'm trying to say
what is calorie density rami
if i give you a bowl of lettuce
versus a bowl of chocolate chips which
one do you think has more calories
chocolate chips chocolate chips if i
give you a bowl of
yeah it tastes better too if i give you
a bowl of vegetables versus a bowl of
let's say uh i don't know butter which
one do you think has more calories
butter the butter right however science
has proven this that your body doesn't
care how many calories you eat bro your
body just cares about the volume more or
less and this is for beginners obviously
right intuitively there's there's you
know the pressure changes in your
stomach and the walls when it expands or
contracts that's what stops ghrelin and
leptin and all these hormones that's
what basically makes you full so if you
have a bowl of vegetables right which is
going to be let's say 50 calories 100
calories but it's really filling
versus a bowl of junk food which is
probably gonna be a thousand calories
they're both going to fill you up the
same however one's going to give you 50
calories one's going to be a thousand
calories
so if you have to eat 2 000 calories a
day you decide if you want to go to
mcdonald's you want to get let's say a
double fillet fish sandwich which has
like 1000 calories you want to add some
fries and drink 1500 calories and then
you get a little mcflurry on the side
you can either eat that or you can eat
six meals of chicken breast and broccoli
now here's the thing why would you go to
either extreme you can you can find the
middle path get a lot of volume right
vegetables is an easy way to do that
because they're very volume heavy but
not calorie heavy meaning they give you
more volume for less calories
and you don't have to binge and worry
about you know why am i always hungry
all the time yeah
on a side note
um i have this issue
where i can't
have certain foods
and um they have like they're called fog
maps and i'm not here to like really
explain
what this is and everything just know
that like
if i eat onions or like garlic and stuff
like that or eggs like for some reason
my body's just like or lactose
blacks was like the worst one of them
all
right but if i eat these things it's
like my body starts reacting and it's
like my stomach is really bloated and
expanding and what's crazy is like
i could you could give me like a few
pieces of onion
i could eat that my stomach will expand
and i actually won't even have hunger so
there was a point in my life where like
i was actually
i wouldn't say anorexia but damn near
close
did you know that on me there was a
point when another was anorexic bro it's
hard to imagine
i mean i'm not that far right now but
yeah
it's um
it got bad because i was trying to put
on weight but it's like all the foods
that i was eating i couldn't eat enough
because
my stomach would just be like expanded
so it's crazy it's like if you actually
want to cut weight it's really not that
hard just
make the foods more
more volume like you could add more like
let's say lettuce
um popcorn is a good one watermelon like
watermelons like
people don't realize watermelon is very
uh watermelon papaya
pineapple's a decent one too uh
strawberries
blackberries raspberries these things
man like they taste delicious and
they're very high volume so you could
eat a whole bunch of it and like by the
time you're full you probably only got
like less than 500 calories let me give
them another jump to add to that bro and
this is gonna be hated by a lot of
people bro
how dare you listen
how many people mistake hunger or
mistake thirst for hunger
i guarantee you this if you're watching
this you're probably dehydrated bro your
lips are chopped up you're always
thirsty all the time you have headaches
i guarantee you this people are not
drinking enough water and the thing with
dehydration is if you you know don't
have this fear you know people have this
this a little misconstrued but the more
water you drink doesn't mean the more
water you retain i don't know where they
got this from you know the more the less
water you drink the more let's take a
step bismuth three for some
i don't have water man
i don't mean what do you have in that
cup have coffee okay so while we have
something to hydrate us something to
dehydrate i'm just playing bro it's all
good coffee is amazing bro shout out to
gabriel armani he talks about you know
the benefits of having coffee every day
uh check that out it's a good fat burner
too that's a little hint but water what
are we talking about water
why are we talking about water guys i
don't know who said this but the more
water you drink the less water you hold
right this is the truth people think if
i drink so much water i'm gonna hold
more no you're holding water because
you're dehydrated you're not giving your
body enough water so it kind of thinks
yo this guy's never drinking water let's
just hold on to whatever bait he does
give us when you finally start drinking
a lot of water you'll flush all this
water weight out i guarantee this to
anyone watching this if you think you're
out of weight your weight is higher or
your bmi is higher than the average
person
don't change your diet don't change your
calories just drink double the water
you're drinking right now or just 1.5
times the water you're drinking right
now just increase the water add another
liter or two to your diet
just watch how your weight just goes
down over the next few days or weeks
that's very true
so there's still a lot to be said about
the physical nutrition um but keeping it
as simple as possible
the next thing that we can talk before
we get into the the physical with
keeping on nutrition
uh
the only thing that you want to focus on
aside from
volume or low like high volume or low
volume if you're bulking
you can do low volume
you know like
you could potentially eat oreos and
fit it into your diet where like that's
all right because you know you have to
eat more calories than someone who's
trying to cut weight
um but obviously like i said if you're
trying to cut weight you would do
do like lettuce you do the high volume
foods now the only thing that you have
to focus on in terms of like
protein fats carbohydrates just make
sure you're getting in enough protein
and that's usually around like 0.8 times
your body weight
and what
oh if it's on pounds if it's kilograms i
think it's on 1.5
maybe maybe it might be higher i'm not
sure
point it meaning if you are going to and
this is a window guys it's not going to
always be like the exact amount but
let's say a guy weighs 150 pounds right
you want to be getting at least 0.8
grams per pound meaning 0.8 times 150
which is going to be 120 right
so 120 but bear in mind if you're 150
and you're you have a lot of muscle
you're going to need more than that and
if you're 150 and you're very overweight
and most of it's fat then you're going
to need less than that right so you got
to keep this in mind but i do want to
piggyback one point that you said about
you know the the
calories if you are someone who's
bulking right i know you said a little
bit is enough but there are a lot of
people that are hard gainers right these
are people that they need three four
thousand calories per day they can't
gain weight for the life of them right
because i don't want to leave these
people out what do you do here go in on
the calorie dense foods do the opposite
of what we're saying for the other
people
go in on foods that are extremely high
calorie a lot of fat and low volume
meaning you could just eat like a bag of
doritos you got 500 calories right there
you can eat and these are not the
healthiest foods obviously but
you can get healthier you know uh ways
of getting calorie-dense foods like mayo
uh
you know
what else someone's trying to say butter
you know all these other nutella peanut
butter these are all things that are 100
calories per spoon
you know
yes rami bro what do you think about
everything so far
i think we talked a lot like 30 minutes
about nutrition i think it's all
definitely good stuff is necessary
because if someone's working out but not
eating right they're not going to see
much progress for sure but i do think uh
the viewers are going to be wondering
you know okay the physical part yeah
yeah
like how do i work out like you know i
got a gym membership but what the heck
do i do when i get in there yeah we'll
say this boy say let's go let's go into
that
so you're all right but i did want to
elaborate as much as possible on the
nutrition because
if you're not doing the nutrition right
but it doesn't matter what you do in the
gym yeah
you're gonna be spinning your wheels out
you know yeah so when it comes to
fitness now
okay
um there are many programs out there
that you can run
but in reality it's just
being consistent
sticking to a program um
[Music]
how many times a week do you want to go
like do you want to go two times a week
do you know three four five six it's up
to you but you have to follow a program
don't try to just go in there and figure
it out on your own
because you're probably not
you know like that was the biggest
mistake i made i had such a big ego
coming into it that i didn't want to
like ask for help i don't want to have a
personal trainer or anything like that
but it's like look it's all right if you
don't know anything just
ask for help you know go on youtube
there's so many videos on youtube where
you have people showing you all the
exercises or go to actual trainer you
know i used to be a trainer if i had
also used to be a trainer
romney
i used to be a trainee you see
nice when you say used to be your tongue
like at gyms like you know yeah we still
do online coaching yeah
but but in terms of like being at a gym
with all the fitness bro i used to be a
trainer you know yeah yeah how long were
you training bro
like maybe three four years what gyms
did you work at i only worked at one gym
that was any time fitness anytime finn
is the 24-hour one yeah the spot the one
and only see i don't like anytime
fitness that much because bro they're
super picky when it comes to bringing
guests
yeah i don't know if you knew that it's
not like la it's not like l.a yeah i
like fitness bro we're down the street
they bring like a couple guests at a
time right yeah yeah mashallah bro i
blessed them i worked at uh one gym
called crunch which is like a franchise
and then i worked in another gym which
is a private gym not gonna mention any
names here
but uh not bad bro but at the end of the
day they overwork you
i don't know that this is a side tangent
we don't want to go too off but people
that are thinking hey should i apply for
personal training listen you're gonna be
doing 95 sales this is not what they're
telling you and then maybe five percent
once you actually get those clients you
could train them but trust me it's a lot
of it's
it's not what you think it is
you know yeah but
you know getting back getting back on
track here
uh it's all right to have a personal
trainer they they can show you
everything they'll
make sure you're doing the form right so
you don't hurt yourself that's very
important you know if you get an injury
then you got to be out to the gym you're
not going to be able to train
so
in that sense
like i said youtube find the program if
you want to do it yourself or just go to
a trainer go to a friend someone that
knows what they're doing
um and
understand that you have to be
consistent like fire was saying in the
beginning
where it's like
building muscle
building lean mass is the best thing
that you can do in the long run in terms
of keeping a leaner physique without
really trying without doing anything
i'm just because the more muscle you
have
you know the body fat ratio goes down
and then also the more muscle you have
muscle burns more calorie at risk
a lot of people don't muscle needs a lot
of calories bro yeah people like dwayne
johnson they need 6 000 calories just to
like replenish their muscle bro there's
no way this guy's gonna get overboard
and store anything as fat if he's still
working out yeah yeah so very simple you
know just be consistent with that and
then
um a lot of people want to know what's
the best thing you can do to lose fat
aside from working out listen just
walk
people don't realize this but like
the low intensity workouts that you do
like walking these are the best for
actually burning fat because
you're not typing into meat
yeah that's the one you're not tapping
into your glycogen storage it's like
romney over here he's a pacer like when
he's on the phone he he just walks back
and forth i used to do this back then
right now i'm cutting so when i'm
cutting my body tries to not move at all
but when i'm not cutting i do exactly
what ramen does i move around all the
time
and um what this does is his body's
basically burning off calories
or burning off the fat that he has
without him even trying to do anything
so i mean if you're trying to lose
weight and then you you are making
yourself consciously going out there and
walking
this does a huge difference you know and
it doesn't always have to be walking it
could be swimming it could be a light
bike ride
it could be painting inside the house it
could be in gardening it's just
something that's very light intensity
but prolonged like you're doing it for a
long period of time if you do that
consistently every single day if you're
training every single week
and you got your nutrition on point
listen within a few months
you're going to be you're going to be
going from a stuff for allah to martial
allah easily bro
when it comes to a consistent fitness
routine and a resistance training
protocol science has proven that you
need at least there's a sweet spot right
because it's like a normal distribution
curve meaning if you do less it's not
effective but if you do too much it's
not effective so there's this optimal
sweet spot i think i think this would be
too much to explain right now okay i
know what you're talking about i love
the details trust me i love the details
you're trying to keep it super
fundamental for like people watching how
about this how about this
we should be asking romney because he's
he's very basic with this understanding
so it's like whatever he can pick up
almost would be probably best rami from
what you've started in your in your
fitness routine what are muscle groups
that beginners should be focusing on and
just some simple exercises that they
could do yeah well as for muscle groups
i'm not going to talk about muscle
groups but what i've been taught so far
is is pull push and leg okay so push
pull legs it's easiest to divide into
those three um all the pushing motions
like bench press right shoulder press um
tricep extensions yeah all that stuff
those are pushing movements and you tend
to use a lot of the same muscles when
you're using pushing movements the same
thing when when you're pulling things
like back when you work your back your
biceps traps um yeah traps and all these
things you're pulling a lot and you tend
to use
the muscle the same muscles a lot like
you'll see if you if you're doing
pull-ups or something you'll feel it in
your back in your back and depending on
how you do it you might feel it in your
biceps as well like you're you're really
pulling you'll see you'll squeeze at the
top and you'll feel it in your biceps
and um that's just how it is when you
work similar you know similar muscles or
similar movements so i would say focus
on the compound movements which are
which are the workouts that work out
multiple muscles at once especially if
you're beginning because as angel was
telling me you want to build a good
foundation when you're first starting
off because as humans i think there's
this kind of unspoken thing when you
walk in the gym like i'm just moving i'm
literally just pushing or i'm just
pulling how hard is it to pull how are i
you know i pull this i pull and push my
couch every day or whatever how hard is
it when you're pushing heavy heavy
weight especially if you have a big ego
you want to lift a lot you're going to
mess something up you're not going to be
doing it the right way like literally
you'll be doing tricep extensions you'll
be feeling it in your shoulders because
you're trying so hard to push down with
your shoulders and then you freaking
like
it just starts burning and then you
can't move your shoulder it hurts and
it's not because you're sore it's
because you you pulled something you did
something wrong so you have to be very
careful
eagle lifting is a real thing bro i want
you all to imagine this with me we're
going to do a little bit quick over
exercise all right you have this guy in
the gym
fat as hell bro like you could tell he's
300 400 pounds but power lifter
mashallah whatever
and he puts on six plates on each side
and he's about to do a deadlift his body
could probably only do two three plates
properly right but he's six plates ego
right but he says he's doing it for a
personal record or whatever and he puts
all this chalk he snorts i've seen them
snort these these things bro that help
you you know slow down your oxygen
retention and lift more and they do all
this ammonia ammonia stuck for a lot bro
at that point what are you doing and
then they slow down
and then they grab the bar
and they lit the the total movement of
the bar for the deadlift is probably one
inch bro
and they're done and then everyone's
like
mashallah or they don't say martial
whatever
good job bro good job paul you did it
rock on and paul just goes on with his
life callous hands and everything bro
what are you doing moving that
displacing that barbell bro one inch
when you could be lifting much less no
ego like ramulo singh and actually feel
something bro subhanallah if you got
proper technique you're not taking five
hour rest periods you're doing one
minute rest periods
little weight goes a long way yeah yeah
and like i guess it's also safe to say i
know you want to jump in here i'll say
this quickly um how you work out take
your time bro
no rush bro come on
i'm rushing a little bit
one thing guys one thing i want to add
is what what your goal is is going to
affect how you work out not just your
staging and working out if you're a
beginner or not but what your goal is um
you know someone who's working out
because they want to enter in like
bodybuilding competitions and they have
the one they want to have the cleanest
looking body the leanest looking spray
turn the heck out of it yeah all that
stuff it's going to look different than
someone who's training you know because
they're a basketball or nfl player
versus someone who's training because
they want to lose fat versus someone
who's training because uh uh they you
know they're a swimmer and they they
need a good athletic body to swim it's
all going to be very different yeah yeah
100 it goes back to what ramen was
saying in the beginning about the
intention
you know as a as a muslim whether you're
a man or a woman
and you are going into working out you
know to better yourself like your
intention has to be very very straight
because if not your ego will come into
the picture like trust
the moment you start looking better and
you look into that mirror
oh it's a slippery slope
you know a good practice
a good practice i was about to say that
i have but i don't even have it so a
good practice that we should all
be doing is to
uh look in the mirror less
you know so that way you can keep your
intention straight
uh i i had heard this from i think it
was the rock
where he says when he works out he
doesn't have mirrors
he doesn't like to look at himself
because it's like you're you're content
with what you see and therefore you're
not going to go as hard that's crazy bro
crazy just thinking about it every time
there's a mirror there i just look at
the pump and i'm just like yo i'm good i
don't need to do more yeah
i'm looking at the pump sometimes i'm
gonna be like damn
oh
look at this
and then you come home and then the pump
goes away and you're like stuck full of
love like what is this
so i was like again have you have your
intention straight what exactly are you
training for
are you just trying to be in better
health because if so
the way you look shouldn't even matter
that's just a byproduct um is your
intention to look better for your spouse
and for yourself okay
well then cool like that's where your
intention is but
again like you gotta have the intention
straight or maybe you're trying to
you're trying to
[Music]
be intimidating like romney said
and fight as well and you're trying to
put up
um i was going to say front but i'm not
i don't want to put it down like that
but you're trying to put a facade like
you are this intimidating person like
you you're just trying to intimidate for
like a bit of words
on a side note guys i want you all to
comment down below right now if you guys
think on hell is intimidating um a lot
of people dm us and they they they say
things in a way where they have
questions for angel i don't know why
yeah i don't i don't get it i'm sure you
don't get out of and they're just like i
have a question for angel but i don't
know if i should ask this or if you'll
take it the wrong like why do y'all
think anno is intimidating bro if you
all know him in real life he's like a
teddy bear bro
i kid you not he's he's he's such a nice
genuine guy bro you know alhamdulillah
but uh
all right but uh
yeah
kisses him no bro all right
it's okay
but guys listen there's nothing else
about that guys for all of you kaladj
over here but let's say this this is the
most important thing one of the most
important things right
i don't want to negate the validity and
importance of testosterone in a man's
health all right yes you know i'm going
to talk about it more on my channel i
don't know if anna's talked about him on
his channel i don't know if rami is
going to start his channel get it up and
running and talk about it on his channel
who knows brad dna day why do we have
four channels who knows but what is
testosterone it is a man's hormone so to
speak do women have testosterone of
course right just like we have estrogen
which is the female dominant hormone but
for our interests and purposes
the
importance of testosterone is like
nothing else
when it comes to a man's physical body
all right it's a gift from allah it's a
mercy from allah if you have immune
problems if you have digestive problems
if you have mental health problems if
you have a lot of these issues it could
just be in diabetes blood pressure all
these illnesses it could just be of low
t low testosterone right
what can we do to boost your
testosterone the first wonderful point
right now which is do compound lifts
what are compound lifts you are doing
lifts that do multiple muscle groups
active at the same time right if you're
doing dead lift if you're doing benching
squatting rolls all these things right
not just doing isolated bicep curl
machine or anything like that nothing
wrong with those but you're lifting uh
multiple muscle groups will basically
force your body to go into super
physiological levels of force exertion
which basically in layman terms
makes your body move more than it's ever
done and use more recruit more muscle
fibers than it's ever done in a while
and that's going to push you into a
level where you're forced to increase
your testosterone and growth hormone
output um what else could you do sleep
more this is key right
so many people i look at and they just
sleep deprived bro
like you just look around and
guys by the way if anyone's wondering i
don't want you guys commenting down
below like oh why is ramy looking like
this today listen
he's just tired bro and the reality is
it's not just him who's tired bro
wallahi all of us are fatigued today
this is this whole rat race work hard 24
7 hustlepreneur listen i understand that
but if you work hard you got to sleep
hard too right and the less you sleep
the less testosterone you're going to
have so pandola bro sleep will do
wonders for your testosterone not just
you know sleep long sleep length but
continuous sleep what is continuously we
can talk about this another day but um i
talk about this a lot with my clients
that there's this thing called the sleep
cycle right it's about 90 minutes the
rem cycle and you don't even really
start producing legit amounts of
testosterone until the third or fourth
sleep cycle which is like a couple hours
in so if you're going to bed and you're
waking up through the night bro you're
gonna wake up a lot and and when you go
back to sleep you're gonna start again
from sleep cycle one right how do you
prevent this don't drink a lot of water
like an hour or two before bed don't eat
right before bed and you know don't be
on your phone like right before you fall
asleep and inshallah you should sleep
deep and if you have no light in your
room but that's a side point anyway yeah
sleep what else having good fats in your
diet what are good fats non-animal fats
no i just said good fats this could be
animal fats which are saturated fats
this could be unsaturated fat from
plants nuts seeds oils fish just don't
have trans fats or try to limit trans
fats right what is trans fats it's
whenever you have an oil and you heat it
up twice
every freaking south asian household bro
i'm coming for you right now they see
households bengali households indian
households pakistani households they
have a big wad of oil right and they
literally like heat that up to like fry
up samosas and pakoras and all that and
then when the temperature cools down
they leave it and they use it the next
day obviously because they don't want to
waste it right
nah bro stop deep frying stuff get an
air fryer or something because any time
you you hydrogenate an oil like you
break up the hydrogen bonds because you
heat it up that's what gives it the heat
to cook the food
anytime you heat it up and it cools down
if you heat it up the second time
it becomes a trans fat and why are we
talking about trans fats
if you want to lose weight right if you
have normal fat cells normal saturated
or unsaturated fat cells
if you lose weight you actually shrink
the cells and you also get rid of the
number of cells however this is
extremely important here if you have
trans fat cells right
are you thinking of transgenders or like
what's going i i'm here bro
tran trans fats
listen if you have trans fat cells in
your body
you can shrink it if you try to lose
weight but you'll never get rid of them
you can never get rid of the amount of
trans fat cells you have you can only
shrink them up that smoke off your face
we're all stuck for a long time
listen but anyway that's what i'm trying
to say so good fats are good why
testosterone is a steroid-based hormone
meaning not steroids we're not trying to
tell people to you know gear up but it's
a fat-based you know lipid-based uh
hormone
why am i saying this the more fats you
eat the more testosterone you will have
not the bad fats but just you know fats
in general animal fats there's a cap but
but good fats yeah and the two last
things i'm going to quickly wrap this up
before we go on uh to really boost your
testosterone like to levels that you
never thought was proper uh angel's
gonna go into one of them which is
talking about xeno and phytoestrogens
which are the environmental things that
might be lowering your testosterone um
where's the plastic bottle bro so we can
give them a demonstration uh and yeah
we're gonna avoid this so anna's gonna
go in on that but i will say the fifth
point before he goes in on that point um
a quick way of really completely nuking
your testosterone level is going to be
vitamin d what is vitamin d vitamin d is
the main precursor to
producing testosterone where do you get
vitamin d subhanallah we don't need
drugs bro we don't need vitamins or
supplements right allah has given us the
sun
and the sun when it shines on you when
you get sun exposure it gives you
vitamin d
most natural way of vitamin d 30 to 60
minutes minimum per day ideally if you
live in northern climate sure then you
can supplement with i don't know four to
five thousand milligrams of vitamin d
that's what i recommend but yeah going
on the xeno and phytoestrogens bro we're
done talking about the trends you want
me to talk about the xeno and the
phytoestrogen okay
um
xeno and phytoestrogens
very complex words
but it's very simple it's basically like
plastics
like this
plastics
is this polyester this is cotton hundred
percent cotton blend cotton is good
cotton is very good
um but like polyester clothing
uh aluminum in your in your
are we're not there yet
there's a lot there's a lot of stuff
it's definitely a lot but
this is
i feel like we're kind of getting like
too much into the details like no no
this is still stuff they deserve to know
bro
the truth shall set them free inshallah
okay keep it simple what should they
replace this with plastic waters
use
glass glass or metal or use
things like this or metal sticker
you're saving the environment too yeah
but if you do have high testosterone
levels you want to lower them yeah
that's by the way you're probably
wondering why do we have these in the
first place um we're trying to actually
lower our testosterone levels because
we're we got what did we get charged for
last week being too aggressive
okay i'll tell them everything
um
[Music]
like polyester clothing
a lot of the workout clothing is
polyester so you all notice that it's
not very comfortable
um cotton clothing is usually like the
most comfortable sometimes you have like
the blends of like cotton and polyester
that's fine
um
but that's listen i don't want to get
into this huge rabbit hole and of itself
why don't you go ahead and say the last
point here so we can kind of like wrap
it all together the last one was a
vitamin d but to quickly just you know
bring it full circle for the xenon
phytoestrogens
guys and girls please
get your
uh aluminum parabens all this bs out of
your your household out of your bathroom
right
there's uh
the deodorant you're putting in is
blocking your endocrine system which is
going down to your balls where your
testosterone is produced in your gonads
medically right um
why am i saying this because you know i
want you to smell i don't want you to
not have deodorant no
there's aluminum free deodorants you can
buy when you go to the store you find
your dove man axe gillette whatever you
uh you know old spice whatever you buy
don't buy gillette whatever you buy
right right next to it you will see the
same thing old spice but aluminum free
right same price by the way bro back
then we have to do some weird stuff with
the crystals and all that right today
supernova they have it so easy yeah they
have it so easy they have the aluminum
free versions right
so it's not gonna smell as good like
you're not gonna smell as good as using
a legit deodorant with aluminum because
those are antiperspirants right they
make you smell
really good and they completely block
you from sweating
but you might have to reapply it a
couple times but that's the first thing
uh make sure you look for stuff like
paraben free from your skincare products
if you use face washes or moisturizers
body washes shampoos conditioners and
i'm gonna end it with that
don't look through the ingredients how
do i know if it has parabens like uh
ethyl paraben methyl pair but you don't
need to look for that all right don't go
that deep
or look for aluminum it's a selling
point meaning if it has no aluminum
it'll say in big letters bigger than the
actual logo aluminum free same with uh
paraben free so if you see any of those
go for it and last but not least
what do they have to swallow one times
per day to maximize testosterone
if they're not having fish i just love
it
when you were talking about the
deodorant you're like yo
like you said like oh back then remember
back in the day we used to
why
you had to get that in the farm boy
i said it because bro
wallahi when we found out these things
and we were researching it was actually
not accessible bro they have it so easy
today they have aluminum free and
everything back then it was tough bro
and those things were like 20 30 bucks a
pop the crystal yes
that's been around since i was a kid bro
but what do they have to swallow that
head what do they have to swallow if
they're trying to maximize their
testosterone
and
it has a lot of testosterone boosting
effects if they're not having fish
it is an omega-3 pill
i think romney how dare you best suited
to answer this question
what did i have to swallow
i even though i already said it do you
remember what i said
i played the fifth
no it's an omega how many times a day do
you
do you swallow this
thousand milligram omega three pill
three to five times a day i didn't even
know that was the thing that's that's
what i was talking about bro get your
stuck for a lot bro well i didn't say
anything this is haram
we're gonna wrap this podcast up too uh
soon guys this is getting unruly if you
guys want andrew tate in the podcast
inshaallah comment down below let us
know you want andrew tate insha allah we
can ask him some deep questions um
number two
there are other things like not wasting
your seed with your hand and screen of
pixels can we talk about this another
episode of course super important um
why are we only talking about episodes
to get you straight before marriage well
marriage is extremely important
and the more people that have successful
marriages the more we can propagate the
ummah and actually make a change in this
world
and to keep it very simple
the uh few points that i mentioned
are the examples actually
okay first example
a guy trying to get married or a woman
trying to get married
they
come on like y'all are gonna try to look
the best that you can possibly look
before you do this
it's simple
okay
now when you get married the biggest
problem is people get comfortable and
they let themselves go therefore the
attraction kind of begins to dwindle
and the relationship kind of goes
downhill from there so now the other
example you have this brother or sister
who they're married
and they either not taking care of
themselves or they are taking care of
themselves like i said
um one is going to lead to the other
one affects the other so if the man is
not taking care of himself the woman
will not take care of herself same vice
versa
um but now let's say you have the
example where
you have
the brother or the sister who is taking
care of themselves okay
when you're in a relationship with
someone and
the other person is taking care of
themselves
two things can happen
either you get extremely jealous
or you step up exactly
or you step up
and that's the biggest thing is like oh
is it both happen you get extremely just
and you step up
but
that's the thing is like
if the man starts stepping up the woman
is going to step up inevitably and if
the woman is stepping up the man's gonna
step up inevitably
um and if if they don't well then
they're just gonna get
left behind and what i say about left
beyond i mean like
the relationship y'all are gonna grow in
different ways and
you know
it might not end with you all being
together yeah either hundo
but if both of y'all
step up if both of y'all are taking care
of each other y'all both are aligned
y'all both are growing in the same path
so
it's it's better for you and i mean bro
like
before we even ended like how do you all
feel when you work out
very good amazing bro
exactly
bro so imagine feeling like that and
then now you're with your wife
and she also feels like that like what
do you think
how good of the relationship do you
think
is gonna be when both y'all are on 100
feeling good
popping bro martial
yeah so it's just something to keep in
mind yeah yeah
inshallah guys the last thing we want to
talk about before we wrap this up is
going to be the secret ingredient it's
going to be you know talked about the
importance of nutrition
working out compound movements
testosterone sleep all of this last
thing is steroids guys um you will want
to use just a little a little goes a
long way they don't actually need too
much oh we weren't supposed to talk
about that okay never mind uh guys word
just don't don't use the words and just
do everything else inshallah you'll be
fine but keeping it simple either
you know go on youtube
and um
gather all the information for yourself
or
to make it real easy
find someone who knows
and have them guide you but don't have
it be
someone who is just gonna do everything
for you to where you depend on them all
the time but like
well they're showing you how to do
things they're they're teaching you
about these things so that you can learn
and eventually
you won't need a trainer
was that a was that a joke about
steroids or
no i mean you don't know use
actually we don't have to talk about
that
i mean if okay like if it's a joke you
should clarify for the viewers and if
not then
that's true see i would i usually carry
jokes to the grave because they make
them more funny but you're right bro
because there's a lot of uh there's a
huge uh responsibility right now that we
have for the umma
i would like to clarify that yes this
was a joke we don't use steroids we
don't promote steroids um in the
traditional sense right but if you are
suffering from low testosterone and
you're in your 30s or 40s
trt a lot of shields have been saying
you know it's permissible if it's you
know affecting your quality of life and
can't get it up can't perform the
natural obligation definitely trt all
for it but people that just want to do
it because they want a shortcut in life
don't do it um i've been working out for
about eight years i don't know how about
you
definitely a couple years right
since you were 16.
have i thought about using steroids yes
but i personally want to see what my
natural body could do what it's capable
of like naturally um
i definitely want to see that so i'm
still like just at it every day what
about you yeah i mean look
the only reason anyone would ever take
steroids
is either one the ego or two
they are in a sport which
you know they need to step up
and it's either they step up or they get
left behind or they're in a in a
like a few where they're making money
off of it like maybe their body is the
way that they make money not only fans
y'all take that out of your mind
but like the fitness influences you know
like on youtube instagram stuff like
that mm-hmm so
ramen did you actually think we took
cigarettes
generally like general questions no no
off-camera
off camera but you know it's going to
stay you know it's going to stay here
yeah but
to finish everything off guys fitness
very very important make sure that you
are taking the time out to learn about
it taking the time out to implement it
in your life
and yeah with that being said
i would like to leave y'all with uh just
a handful
of advice before we leave you because
i understand a lot of the reason y'all
don't take things to the next level or
get professional coaches like me or
angel or rami or any of these things is
because there's a financial aspect right
and and i get it bro if you're young
you're trying to make money you can
still make progress you won't make as
much progress as having a legit
professional coach but you could still
do it so i'll give you guys some
youtubers that we recommend just before
we wrap it up let's say five youtubers
i'll give three you give two um because
i'm better than you and uh there's a lot
of with the fitness youtubers just
understand you got to go in at your own
discretion and they're not muslim most
of the time yeah they're not proper
sadafi whatsoever salafia so don't
expect the outer to be covered don't
expect them to have uh you know
or anything like that
that's what i was trying to say
number one person i would recommend is
joe delaney i was gonna say that okay
now you gotta get someone else number
two person i was i'll say is uh jeff
nippard or nepard n-i-p-p-a-r-d oh it's
over bro and number three person i will
say is athlean x and this is it oh and
this is for rehabilitation more so so
any of the two you wanna give two
um anyone extra that i would recommend
honestly man like
the heart's twenties no no
no see jeff nipper he breaks everything
down like very scientifically very well
um
[Music]
i think next man like he just
everything's just so like on point in
terms of like the physiological
standpoint then i think it's more
technical yeah i can give two if you
can't i can i can give more but like
these three encompass like these two are
good things
joe delaney he's like
this man just he we need to get him on
the podcast he's open-minded so yeah he
is but
any time i see like his videos i'm like
yo marshall like you would actually make
a good muslim bro
bro i was just going to say have you
seen the spiritual videos and like yeah
did you see the one where he was talking
about the um
the natural hi
yeah oh man yeah oh he was saying so
much stuff i was like bro like this is
what
we should invite him bro
the last one i will say number four but
definitely not least his name is
remington james he does a little bit of
meal prep videos so for the people that
have no creativity let's say they have
no type of direction or
type of specificity and how do i make
the perfect diet calories this that
other remington james is a perfect
youtuber to find out how to do meal prep
and he's like the king of milk inshallah
yeah this is like mostly men that we
just said
this is all men actually zone men yeah
because we're not watching women we're
not watching that's true but
what about for the muslims uh ask your
sister bro i don't know
sucks sucks to be all right now
how dare you but they can get uh they
can get a lot from geoff nippert they
can get a lot from geoff nippert and
charlotte chill the eyes though cause
his outer is just and that's for the men
too and i'm just playing that's that's
the thing bro that you can't you can't
navigate the world
easily if you if you're if you're you
know there's ways around it you can you
know maybe just listen to it or anything
but trust me at the end of the day it's
the lesser of two evils right and
there's not
advice or anything like that but if you
had to pick between staying fat as hell
and unhealthy and
huffing and puffing climbing stairs like
anh was saying and you're not having
intimacy you're not gonna have kids you
know you're made or
you watch jeff nippard which one should
they pick
i don't think we're well we'll leave you
all to judge right because
but with that being said insha allah
rami will end it off if you gain
something from this episode stay tuned
for next week where we go into mental
health because the physicality is not
everything but it is something
let's go work out insha'allah
you're going to work out bro yeah let's
do it man you sure yeah
yes
guys listen
still we're still going we don't leave
this part up we weren't going to work
out before because you know we were
tired you were tired
was already going rami was already tired
like we didn't even want to film this
episode but inshallah we grinded this
through and now we're going to go work
out inshallah what are we doing legs
let's do legs tonight yeah let's do legs
inshaallah all right i don't want to
work out anymore
my
um
um
[Music]